وعلى صعيد التطورات الميدانيه قالت
السلطات المواليه لروسيا في دنياتسكينا
مدنيين اثنين قتل جراء قصف اوكرانيا
استهدف المدينه واشارت السلطات لان القوات
الاوكرانيه قصفت اربع مناطق سكنيه باكثر
من 30 قذيفه بما في ذلك احياء وسط المدينه
واوضحت السلطات ان القصف الحق اضرارا
ماديه بمباني سكنيه عده ومرافق البنيه
التحتيه المتاني
ة اشكر الزميل ناجي ذكرنا
وينضم الينا الان من دونيتس كمراسله
الجزيره رانيا الدريدي رانيا اهلا بك اذا
اخر التطورات في جبهات الشرق بعين روسيه
دائما
نحن متواجدون يعني منذ صباح اليوم اعلنت
السلطات المحليه هنا عن استهداف حي كيف
خلال ساعه واحده بنحو 20 صاروخا من
الراجمات حتى هذه اللحظه لا نزال بين
الفين والاخرى نسمع لذوي انفجارات في
مناطق متفرقه هذا التزامن مع اعلان
السلطات المحليه ايضا عن مقتل مدنيين في
القصف الاوكراني الذي استهدف هذه المنطقه
احياء مدينه وايضا احياء في المقاطعه تم
استهدافها بنحو 30 قذيفه خلال ساعه
الاربعه والعشرين الماضيه ما تسبب باضرار
ماديه طالت عدد من المباني السكنيه ومباني
البنى التحتيه بحسب السلطات ايضا لابد من
الاشاره الى ان القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
بحسب تصريحات الصادره عن السلطات المواليه
الموالي لروسيا فيروج تم استهداف ايضا
مستودعات في محطه للقطارات في مدينه
ميليتوبل
تسبب هذا يعني ايضا عن الانقطاعات في
الطاقه الكهربائيه في المدينه والقرى
المجاوره المجاوره وهنا الاشاره لان هذا
القصف لمقاطعه ياتي بالتزامن ايضا مع
وصول مدير الوكاله الدوليه لطاقه الذريه
دفاييل جروسي الى محطه النوويه
للاطلاع على امنها وعملها وهنا اود
الاشاره الى ان عمليات التفتيش والاطلاع
على هذه المحطه كانت قد بدات فعليا قبل
قليل سفيان هذا من جهه من جهه اخرى لو
تحدثنا عن تصورات الاوضاع في باخموت بوافق
للمصادر العسكريه المطلعه الروسيه فان
هناك محاولات للقوات قوات باكثر في هذه
المنطقه للسيطره على الاجنحه العسكريه
المتاخمه والمحيطه بمدينه الحديث يدور
بالدرجه الاولى عن المناطق الشماليه
الغربيه العسيمه منطقه اريخ ابواب سيلوفكا
وايضا بغداد نفقه ايضا تقوم القوات فاغن
باسته مواقع القوات الاوكرانيه في مدينه
شاصيار وهنا ود التفكير بان هذه المدينه
مدينه شاصه كانت المركز الذي مركز الدعم
الاوكراني الذي كان يتم ارسال عبره
المعدات العسكريه والقوات الى القوات
الاوكرانيه العامله في داخل المدينه فضلا
عن ذلك وفقا للمعطيات الصادره هنا هناك
تقدم لقوات فاغنر في مختلف المحاور في
داخل المدينه لاسيما في المناطق المركزيه
القوات تتقدم من الجانبين من الجهتين
الشماليه والجنوبيه ايضا التطورات والاعين
الان موجهه الى مدينه افديفكا قد تكون
بحسب تصريحات الصادره هنا يعني وضعها حال
وضع مدينه باخمت القوات المسلحه الروسيه
حاليا تحاول محاصره هذه المدينه من مختلف
الاتجاهات الاسيمه من الشمال والجنوب
وكانت سلطات المحليه هنا اشارت الى ان وضع
القوات الاوكرانيه في داخل هذه المدينه
بات صعبا للغايه وهنا ودت التذكير ايضا
بتصريحات صداره اليوم عن مندوب روسيا
الدائم لدى المنظمات الدوليه
اولياء مثلا الذي اشار الى ان مساله
السيطره على هذه المدينه هي مساله ايام او
اسابيع وهنا اود التذكير ايضا بالتصريحات
الصادرهم بمجرد السيطره على هذه المدينه
فان عمليات قصف لمدينه دانيت ستقل بكثير
وايضا للمدن المتاخمه
شكرا جزيلا لك